hello salut à tous bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition d' europe hebdo on est
ici à bruxelles au parlement européen
dans cette édition je vous emmène à
calais frontière nord de l'espace
schengen depuis des mois cette ville du
nord pas de calais fait la une de
l'actualité et pour cause deux mille
trois cents migrants squattent les
abords de la ville dans l'attenté d'un
passage en angleterre une situation
humanitaire difficile et un symbole de
l'échec de la politique migratoire
européenne depuis plus de dix ans mais
d'abord l'actualité jean claude juncker
au coeur du cyclone plusieurs journaux
ont révélé une pratique de taxes ruling
au luxembourg des accords secrets qui
permettent aux entreprises d'échapper à
l'impôt alors l'ancien premier ministre
du grand duché et tout nouveau président
de la commission européenne peut-il
jouer aux repentis c'est la question de
la semaine par simon barbarie
il flottait comme un parfum de malaise
la semaine dernière à la commission
européenne
ici le passé était en train de rattraper
son tout nouveau président jean claude
juncker et oui à peine quelques semaines
après son entrée en fonction est déjà un
premier scandale le luxe l'x les
journalistes d'investigation du monde
entier révèle des accords secrets mis en
place au luxembourg au profit de
centaines de multinationales comme apple
cliquer à ou amazon objectif l'évasion
fiscale c'est ce qu'on appelle le taxent
ruling à la clé des milliards d'euros de
perdus pour les états membres où ces
entreprises réalisent leurs bénéfices
ancien premier ministre du grand-duché
pendant 20 ans jean claude juncker était
quelque peu embarrassé face à ces
révélations la commission fera son
travail oit jean-marc tiendrait à
l'anc est menée par la commissaire
européenne à la concurrence margaret
weis tagueurs devra déterminer si cette
pratique de taxes ruling et qui voit une
subvention d'état déguisé ce qui est
illégal en attendant jean claude juncker
se cache après avoir annulé une
conférence sur l'europe il n'a pas
encore répondu aux demandes
d'explication des eurodéputés après tout
que le luxembourg soit un paradis fiscal
est ce une nouveauté
comment feindre la surprise pour la
coalition des députés conservateurs
libéraux et socialistes qui l'ont élu
alors jean claude juncker président de
la commission européenne peut-il être un
repenti
jean claude juncker peut-il être un
repenti pour répondre à cette question
c'est pervenche berès que je reçois
bonjour merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
présidente de la délégation socialiste
française quand vous voyez un petit peu
ce qui s'est passé ces dernières ces
derniers jours sur la question du luxe
leaks finalement on pousse des cris
d'orfraie mais on ne découvre rien d'une
certaine manière moi je trouve que cette
enquête est bienvenue
on aurait pu la faire plutôt on aurait
pu au moment où le parti populaire
européen choisissait jean claude juncker
comme candidat à la présidence de la
commission imaginez que les journalistes
ou les enquêteurs se mobilisent pour
dire qu'ils étaient jean claude juncker
premier ministre du luxembourg pendant
des années vous savez un cash
investigations que voilà les missions
qui étaient d'exactions france 2 avait
d'ores et déjà sortie exacte artisans
ceux qui aujourd'hui
disent leur surprise ou donne ça comme
une information nouvelle se raconte à
eux mêmes des histoires et là où je dis
que c'est très bien que ça vienne au
faux au début du mandat de monsieur
juncker c'est que ça l'obligent ça le
met devant ses responsabilités
il est maintenant président de la
commission dans un moment où les états
membres doivent lutter avec
détermination contre la fraude contre
l'évasion fiscale et il est en
responsabilité comme présidente vous y
croyez jean claude juncker repenti vous
y croyez en tout cas je ferai tout pour
qu'il le soit et je constate que depuis
qu'il n'est plus premier ministre du
luxembourg et bien un grand pas a été
fait en faveur de la transparence de la
transparence avec ce qu'on appelle l'
échange automatique d'informations je
note par ailleurs qu'il a désigné le
commissaire français pierre moscovici
pour s'occuper des questions de
fiscalité
la personne responsable du portefeuille
de la fiscalité c'est pierre moscovici
marga dasté guerre qu'on voit dans votre
reportage qui responsable de la
concurrence mène les enquêtes et à
partir de ces résultats il faudra que
ces deux commissaires travailler
ensemble pour en tirer les leçons
monsieur jean claude juncker dit qu'il
ne va pas s'en occuper alors il ne doit
pas empêcher que le travail soit fait et
il doit au contraire veiller à ce qu'il
doit faire et ça c'est sa responsable
alors le groupe des libéraux démocrates
et le groupe d demande une commission
d'enquêté parlementaire vous aussi ça
fait partie des initiatives dont on doit
des bars train mais si on mène une
commission denquête il ne faut pas
considérer que ne ferions rien en
attendant les résultats de cette
commission denquête parce qu'encore une
fois indépendamment de savoir si on a
une commission denquête ou pas on sait
que ce problème existe c'est oui mais
alors à partir du moment où il ya une
enquête de la commission les
parlementaires doivent aussi faire leur
enquête par ailleurs on a eu des
commissions spéciales 4 donc là
aujourd'hui les verts et les libéraux le
demande pourquoi les socialistes ne le
demande pas nous en discutons dans
quelques instants j'imagine qu'au moment
où vous diffuserez cette édition le raid
est prise vous pouvez bonne exposition
personnelle mes relations personnelles
il est tout à fait favorable et je parle
en tant que présidente de la délégation
socialiste française bien sûr sujet sur
les c'est un sujet sur lequel je pense
les socialistes français ont des
contributions à apporter parce que c'est
un thème sur lequel nous avons travaillé
depuis longtemps et sur lequel nous
avons des revendications ils demandent
depuis longtemps mais je veux faire un
lien ici avec l'actualité la commission
européenne vient de rentrer en fonction
elle va présenter son programme de
travail nous devons être intraitables
sur la façon dont dans ce programme de
travail la question des relations avec
les pays tiers en matière fiscale la
question de l'harmonisation des bases
fiscales au sein de l'union européenne
la façon dont l'union europenne
s'équipent pour lutter contre l'évasion
et la fraude fiscale devient une
priorité véritable oui mais là je vais
je vais me faire un petit peu l'avocat
du diable mais ça fait quand même des
années qu'on entend parler de ce serpent
de mer de l'harmonisation fiscale de la
lutte contre l'évasion fiscale est-ce
que c'est pas une fois de plus
des grandes promesses c'est
dire que les promesses qu'on ne fait
jamais qu'on ne peut pas un jour mettre
en oeuvre et parfois il ya des combats
que vous avez commencé qui finissent par
devenir réalité dans cette mandature il
ya une promesse qu'on a fait depuis
longtemps qu'il se servir des élections
au parlement européen pour désigner le
président de la commission et bien il y
en a une autre qu'on fait depuis
longtemps qui est de d'harmoniser par
exemple les bases fiscales de l'impôt
sur les sociétés le parlement européen a
pris une position très nettement en
faveur d'une telle initiative
maintenant à nous de mener la bataille
politique pour que au sein du conseil
les chefs d'état et de gouvernement se
mettent d'accord pour aller de l'avant
est ce que jean claude juncker n'est pas
fragilisé et un peu décrédibilisée dans
ce combat justement au vu de ce qui a
été révélé ces derniers jours mais ça ça
dépend de lui maintenant c'est à lui de
dépasser ça veut dire 8 même ne peut pas
on me dit qu'il est terré mais je me
demande pourquoi ce clic se taire parce
qu'il pouvait pas imaginer qu'il allait
passer cinq ans comme président de la
commission sauf qu'un jour quelqu'un lui
rappelle qu'il a été pris la dépendance
en gaz iwuy alors je voudrais revenir
sur les soutiens qu'il a pu recevoir et
des soutiens assez étonnant on réécoute
car moscovici et michel sapin
l'union européenne est là pour faire en
sorte
une pétition la concurrence soit
équitable
chacun avec des gens se régale sur le
marché intérieur la lutte contre l'
optimisation fiscale ça doit être
mondiale
initiation fiscale c'est pas un pays
c'est pas un groupe de pays c'est le
monde entier parfois des tout petits
pays entourée d'eau avec plein de
palmiers à cela aussi il faut il faire
très attention
finalement on l'entend bien de la part
de pierre moscovici et michel sapin il
ya une volonté de dédramatiser et de
dire que c'est un problème global les
etats unis ont signé il ya quelques
temps l'accord facteurs qui justement
avance énormément sur ces questions
d'évasion fiscale et d'échangé
d'informations entre les banques et les
états unis où est-ce qu'on en quoi
l'europe est à la traîne parfois et les
bonnes initiatives qui viennent des
états unis et quand elles sont venues
lorsqu'il faut les suivre et moi je
pense qu'une des
désavantages de cet accord qui a été
passée par les américains justement
c'est de stimuler les européens il les
oblige à regarder un petit peu de vent
encore une fois je pense que l'accord
qui a été trouvé dans le cadre de l'osce
et deux pour les changes automatique
d'informations est une étape absolument
fondamental et on est aussi dans un
moment où les états membres ont besoin
de récupérer
janvier recettes fiscales 1 donc
j'espère que cette situation à les
pousser à les inciter à aller de l'avant
alors justement vous parlez de récupérer
des recettes on entend beaucoup parler
on attend des informations d'ici fin
décembre sur le plan de 300 milliards
que jean claude juncker a annoncé
en juillet dernier lors de son accession
à la présidence de la commission qu'est
ce que vous attendez de ce plan ou alors
il faut bien
dire à ceux qui nous écoutent ses 300
milliards c'est pas juste comme ça un
chiffre pour faire plaisir pour moi le
fait qu'on parle ce plan de 300
milliards c'est en fait qu'on reconnaît
que quelque chose n'allait pas dans la
situation précédente que la situation
précédente a conduit à une situation
structurelle
dans tous les états membres de
sous-investissement et donc au fond il
faut pas que ces 300 milliards ce soit
pour solde de tout compte à la fois
investir ses 300 milliards et aussi
regardez qu'est ce qui fait qu'on a été
dans cette situation de sauver alors par
exemple pour être clair est-ce que vous
vous attendez à ce que les projets qu
bomb donc ses projets en fait c'est
cette capacité d'emprunt qu'on pourrait
avoir autant l'union européenne via la
banque européenne d'investissement soit
relancé mais bien sûr c'est une des
capacités que l'union 1-2 d'être d'avoir
un effet de levier pour susciter de
l'investissement mais il y a un lien
entre les deux sujets que nous venons
d'aborder qui est majeur c'est que moi
je ne voudrais pas que à travers ce plan
de 300 milliards en favorise le
développement d'une croissance de la
création de richesses et que celle-ci
échappent à la fiscalité la
redistribution et lorsque monsieur jean
claude juncker fait par exemple de
l'avancée de l'europe vers une économie
numérique de l'investissement dans le
digital je le soutiens mais en échange
je levais dit le jour de son investiture
eh bien il faut être exemplaire sur la
fiscalité d'apple google d'amano annexe
et amazon parce que sinon nous n'aurons
pas le retour sur investissement way or
ça c'est pas possible merci beaucoup
pervenche berès d'avoir répondu à nos
questions nous on continue direction
calais depuis des mois cette ville du
nord de la france est de nouveau au
coeur de l'actualité et pour cause deux
mille trois cents migrants y campent
tous les jours dans la tente de leur
passage en angleterre c'est aussi la
frontière nord de l'espace schengen et
du coup on a voulu aller voir sur place
comment les habitants et les forces de
l'ordre se gérait tout cette situation
c'est un reportage de sagna déchire
mounir souci monté par yoann oiseaux
chaque jour des dizaines de ferries
traverse la manche calais et son port
c'est la dernière frontière avant
l'angleterre la porte de sortie de
l'espace schengen la promesse d'une vie
meilleure pour des milliers de migrants
bloqués ici
respect voilà l'endroit où je dors dans
cette tente
comme vous pouvez voir ces trombes et
puis à fuir la fête nous avons peur de
l'hiver lorsqu'on est physiquement
faible on ne peut pas résisté à ce
climat l'udc en deux sets
hamad à 29 ans avant de quitter son pays
il était avocat mais il a dû fuir le
darfour région soudanaise en guerre
depuis 2003 où sa vie était menacée
les vrais camp est sûre et non un nombre
de personnes qui a rarement été vu sur
le sur le territoire en tout cas qu ces
dernières années et qui demande une
réponse urgente actuellement
l'an dernier qu'elle et comptait environ
300 migrants ils sont aujourd'hui plus
de 2300 comme ahmad la plupart fui d'une
zone de conflit et sont donc éligibles
au droit d'asile
personnellement peu importe où en europe
si j'ai une occasion je la saisirai
beaucoup se disent prêts à aller
n'importe où mais de préférence en
grande-bretagne alors on va passer d'un
côté à des stations service
vous allez vous suivre et c'est avec un
petit peu de chance de vous montrer
comment ces gars essaient de se cacher
dans les camions
et c'est pas facile mais on estime qu'il
y en a 10 entre 10 et 50 qui arrive à
passer chaque nuit
donc vous avez des migrants qui essaient
de se cacher dans le camion mais ils ne
savent pas si le camion ira en
angleterre ou pas
kelly depuis quinze ans symbole de
l'échec des politiques migratoires
en 2002 la fermeture du camp de sangatte
avait repoussé les migrants dans les
bois une jungle démantelée elle aussi en
désormais dispersées dans plusieurs
camps ils ne peuvent compter que sur
l'aide des associatifs comme christian
bénévoles de l'auberge des migrants
voyons
ok
si calais concentre aujourd'hui autant
de migrants natacha bouchart maire de
calais en est convaincu c'est parce que
l'europe n'a jamais harmoniser sa
politique d'asile quel est le problème
européen numéro un aujourd'hui c'est le
problème du flux migratoires c'est la
stratégie qui n'a pas été écrite c'est
le manque de contact entre pays
européens
c'est le manque de solidarité
en attendant que les états européens
coopèrent les associatifs eu échanges et
s'organisent
c'est
vraiment là ça va il est chaussé ils
sont encore plus
grande bretagne les demandeurs d'asile
sont logés ils ont une allocation
mensuelle
la gale
je suis vraiment choqué et bouleversé
car ces migrants vivent ici à calais
dans des conditions proches de celles
que j'ai vu dans les camps au darfour
des camps de réfugiés de l'onu voire des
tentes de l'armée la solution commence à
être évoquée par certains associatif
inquiet al'approche de l'hiver de voir
les migrants dormir dehors
quel est donc frontière nord de l'espace
schengen symbole de 15 ans d'échecs de
politique migratoire de l'union
européenne pour en parler je reçois de
david coburn bonjour david vous êtes
député anglais membres du you keep est
coincé pardon excusez moi soyons précis
membre du parti you keep de nigel
farrage et pascal rain tienne vous êtes
chef de mission de l'oim iem
l'organisation internationale pour les
migrations
david coburn je me tourne vers vous pour
vous c'est l'échec de l'europe calais ou
c'est juste l'échec de la politique
migratoire de leurs
jeux demandant simple question simple
pourquoi ils passent beaucoup de prêts
avant il arrive à la frontière entre
français et vous arrive pour la plupart
par l'italie par la frontière est sur
que c'est pas en question de ça essayer
malgré ces migrations
pour un travail mais quand il vient en
angleterre c'est pour fait beaucoup de
presse de problèmes pour la santé
ces problèmes pour le logement est aussi
prend le travail des gens en angleterre
ça c'est pas bon alors si elle est tirée
par le nombre ils ont des logements et
aussi les d'argent et la france il pas
fait ça parce qu'il ya un système
différent c'est juste les contres loir
qui qui plus est l'argent pas pour être
faire le centre 25 effectivement en
angleterre ils sont pris en charge par
la collectivité même si david cameron il
y a environ un an a considérablement
restreint les aides auxquelles les
migrants ont droit quoi qu'il en soit je
réitère ma question est ce que pour vous
c'est l'échec de l'europe ou c'est juste
l'échec d'une politique migratoire ou
est-ce que vous en mettre de ce point de
vue là vous au parti ukip est ce que
vous voulez juste fermer les frontières
ou est ce que vous êtes d'accord pour
dire il nous faut aussi une politique
d'asile global c'est les îles sais c'est
pas bien que déjà on vient ici il ya
beaucoup d autres pays restent donc et
si michael lui préfère un système qu'on
aura skalli qui est venue de choisir les
gens qui est si bien pour notre économie
mais les gréements émigration
son choix d'y contrôler c'est impossible
et aussi manon à calais ça c'est à 13
voix pour les maladies
je sais pas qu'est ce qui se passe peut
être ebola je ne sais pas c'est pas
parce que vraiment c'est pas bien paul
et des citoyens décalé et c'est pas bon
pour angleterre les gens viennent en
angleterre nous ne connaît pas ici et
les
messieurs programme les gens qu'on a à
calais ne viennent pas des zones où
ebola je ne sais pas
ils viennent du soudan d'erythrée
d'afghanistan mais je pense que monsieur
reyntjens est beaucoup plus précis que
moi sur cette question vous êtes vous
connaissez bien ce territoire est ce que
pour vous on a laissé pourrir la
situation quelle est votre lecture en
fête de ce symbole d'échec que peut être
calé je ne dirais pas échec je pense je
pense qu'en fait on est sûr sur un mode
complexe au niveau européen et ses
traditionnelles au niveau européen
trouvé une harmonisation sur l'asile
c'est un processus qui est en route
depuis maintenant une dizaine d'années
on n'y est toujours pas arrivé on parle
beaucoup de solidarité inter états on
n'y est pas encore arrivé non plus on a
vu entre autres sur la méditerranée le
fait que marie nostrum se termine qui
est l'opération en fait mis en place en
italie pour venir en aide en fait aux
bateaux donc donc on a une diminution
des financements qui sont qui sont
apportées à ce genre d'opération et on a
entre autres au niveau de ces opérations
le fait d'aller plus vers des opérations
de contrôle que les que des opérations
de sauvetage des vies moi je rappelle
malgré tout que tous les migrants qui
sont là sont des êtres humains je pense
qu'il est primordial de leur apporter
une assistance
appartement où ils sont là je pense
aussi qu'il est primordial de pouvoir
mettre en place une coordination au
niveau européen est un vrai dialogue
entre les différents états qui sont
touchés par les flux migratoires et je
rappelle aussi que ces flux migratoires
sont de plus en plus important entre
autres due au conflit au conflit de plus
en plus proche de l'union européenne par
rapport à ce qui se passait auparavant à
vue en syrie notamment à bord de la ssi
rien on parle de l'on parle de
l'erythrée on parle du soudan enfin tout
ça ce sont des pays qui sont
relativement proches de l'union
européenne est alors pour revenir à ce
que disait monsieur monsieur six mois
anne sicco berne je pense effectivement
que la grande bretagne est ressenti
comme étant un eldorado par pas mal de
migrants quelle que soit la politique
d'asile harmoniser ou non harmonisées je
pense que il ya beaucoup de migrants qui
à partir de leur pays d'origine sont
poussés à quitter ce pays pour
différentes raisons donc il ya des gens
c'est pour des raisons politiques
d'autres pour des raisons économiques
mais le but le but ultime qu'il passe
par la france qu'ils passent par
l'italie qui passe par la belgique où
d'autres pays c'est très souvent la
grande bretagne qui est ressenti comme
étant comme étant l' eldorado alors
justement david coburn vous est
ressentie comme est un eldorado il ya
aussi quelque chose qui est liée à la
langue la plupart de ces migrants sont
anglophones et on le voit bien dans le
reportage il y en a beaucoup qui sont
anglophones donc il est logique pour eux
d'aller vers un pays où ils connaissent
la langue non c'est pas logique y aller
en egypte et ses plus proches pourquoi
il vit en angleterre évidemment
évidemment il parle en anglais mais
c'est pas dit si on va prendre un autre
langage et par français et par exemple
ça c'est pas je suis sûr certains
beaucoup des gens là bas ils prennent
ils le prendraient france français
concédant faudrait revenir sur les
besoins migratoire de l'angleterre
l'année dernière on avait été faire un
reportage sur les besoins de main
d'oeuvre notamment dans l'agriculture
anglaise et on s'est rendu compte que
beaucoup d'anglais localement ne voulait
pas faire ce type de travaux et que du
coup localement les les patrons avaient
besoin de cette main d'oeuvre qu'est ce
que c'est parce que les d'argent c'est
pas suffi parce que 12 mai retour des
migrants sa
dépression des salaires évidemment pour
à quelqu'un donc en bretagne pour
populeux
le hip hop et les maisons les enfants
tout ça c'est trop cher produits il
n'est pas dans les
social mais les gens aimeraient qui
vient et d'ondés social et dans les
logements et tout ça c'est impossible et
aussi un pôle santé le prêt sur la santé
quand j'ai 13 ans globale sur les pôles
de santé aux gars c'est gratuit et c'est
m bref c'est pas gratuit il se paye pour
les contribuables oui si vous avez à
les gens sans limite c'est un pro silva
a fait les décisions au sujet de la
future de son service santé est alors
aussi justement à ce propos nous avons
interrogée la maire de calais qui avait
une petite réflexion dont elle voulait
vous faire part je voudrais qu'on écoute
cheyenne n'a pas mis de clause de
revoyure de point de situation par
rapport aux événements internationaux
aujourd'hui ce qu'il faudrait c'est que
il y ait cette révision des accords de
schengen pour faire une stratégie
globale européenne où tous les pays
d'europe
serait dans l'obligation pour rester
dans l'union européenne
d'adhérer au dispositif de schengen 2
monsieur reyntjens à ce qu il suffirait
que l'on réforme schengen et qu'on fasse
entrer mais je suis pas sûr que mathieu
gaudin soit d'accord l'angleterre dans
l'espace schengen pour régler ces
problématiques très clairement non je
pense je pense que ce serait une réponse
trop trop simple entre guillemets bien
sûr bien sûr qu'il faut probablement
réviser repenser schengen qui a été
créée il ya bien longtemps maintenant
qui a permis je le rappelle malgré tout
une mobilité intra européennes sans
précédent par rapport à ce qui se
faisait par le passé ceci dit moi j'ai
envie de vous donner un chiffre oui si
on prend le conflit syrien on se rend
compte que les pays voisins de la syrie
accueille pour l'instant trois millions
de personnes déplacées et de réfugiés
syriens dont entre 1 et 2 millions en
turquie je rappelle aussi qu'au niveau
de l'union européenne on est on est
occupé à élaborer des plans pour
éventuellement réinstaller cinquante
mille de ces personnes c'est pour vous
donner quelque part finalement les 2300
migrants qu'on ait un calais représente
pas grand chose
je crois mon message aussi c'est de dire
la solidarité au niveau régional elle
existe déjà au niveau de la turquie du
liban des pays voisins de la syrie
je laisse de côté aussi la question de
la libye elle-même qui n'a pas les
capacités pour l'instant de gérer ces
flux migratoires
malheureusement et je reste convaincu
que l'europe doit pouvoir quelque part
travailler sur le développement des
capacités de ce qu'on appelle les pays
de transit je reste convaincu que
l'europe doit aller plus loin dans la
solidarité avec les pays de zone de
conflit je reste aussi convaincu qu'il
faut sauver des vies ici et maintenant
ça a été dit je pense que la question de
la santé la santé individuelle des
migrants est primordial les questions de
santé publique sont aussi primordiale
alors le fait de devoir et ce qu'il faut
mettre en place des centres d'accueil
sur sur calais tel qu'on l'a fait au
niveau de sangatte je pense qu'à partir
du moment où les migrants sont là il
faut s'en occuper via les associations
via des relais éventuellement via un
centre est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec monsieur coburn quand il dit que
effectivement il ya aussi une forme de
dumping social quand on a énormément de
migrants comme ça qui peuvent arriver
alors c'est c'est son point de vue en
angleterre vaste majorité des gens sont
des jeunes hommes c'est pas des femmes
des enfants il ya les femmes et des
enfants a calé il a aussi des femmes et
des enfants est ce que sur cette
question là
il ya quelque chose à répondre en fait
oui je confirme effectivement qu'il y a
qu'en quand on parle de l'eldorado au
niveau des migrants puisque puisqu'on a
un mélange ici dans la discussion sur la
question du droit d'asile et
l'harmonisation du droit d'asile et puis
quelque part la question de la migration
économique
et social oui on peut répondre qu
effectivement la pression migratoire est
probablement trop grande vert vers
l'angleterre ça c'est un fait que la
solidarité est nécessaire et je reviens
sur un point primordial je pense qu'il
faut qu'on aille plus loin sur la
coopération intra européennes au niveau
des différents pays et est en ce compris
les financements qu'ils doivent pouvoir
impliquer tous les états qui sont
touchés par la question migratoire donc
je ne dis pas qu'il faut ouvrir les
frontières je dis qu'il faut continuer à
gérer au mieux et ensemble bon david
coburn donc vous vous dites
qu'il faut fermer les frontières
complètement pas complètement mais nous
avons un système comme australie j'ai
choisi les gens bien quelqu'un qui
viendrait mais par migration sans limite
pour nous la meilleure chose pour couper
le nez gordien et
partirait bien alors oui effectivement
de toute façon c'est la manière dont
vous présentez les choses c'est que de
toute façon quoi qu'il arrive l'idée
pour les you keep c'est de quitter
l'europe lorsque je sois pas c'est
impossible à changer de système il 28
nations en europe c'est pas possible
rongé chose je suis ici ce qui se passe
on sera amenés david coburn à en
reparler largement messieurs merci
beaucoup d'avoir pu débattre avec nous
cette question nous on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine à bruxelles bonne
suite de programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires ciao